[Musique]
l'art comme support d'épanouissement
c'est une idée mise en pratique au foyer
d'accueil occupationnel de la maison
pierrelagourg de l'association apage à
Sainte-Marie l'établissement accueille
des personnes porteuses de handicap
psychique et physique pendant 3 jours
deux artistes plasticiens ont proposé
une initiation à des techniques
d'expression Laurent Pantaléon vidéaste
et photographe propose le CEN typ en
fait c'est le canotype c'est une
technique qui date depuis 1800 et il y a
plein de photographe qu' l'utilise
encore maintenant les produits utilisés
sont pas du tout toxiques sont
accessibles c'est de produits qui sont
accessibles donc tout le monde peut
pratiquer cette épreuve ouais l'avantage
là du procédé c'est qu'on n jamais dans
le noir c'est toutes les opérations tout
le process se passe en pleine lumière
que ce soit le mélange de chimie
l'étalement de la chimie sur le papier
cançon et là le développement ça se
passe en pleine lumière en fait le
papier il est sensible pas à la lumière
donc on peut le faire en pleine lumière
il est sensible aux UV donc on met au
soleil c'est qu'on récupère les UV c'est
comme du bronzage en fait là ça a été
bronzé tout
simplement cette technique est
accessible les apprentis développeurs de
photographie ont bien assimilé le
process un
produit produit chimi c'est ça et
mélangve les cuillère la
balance après là fait mettre de l'eau
après après nous la PE des
fa en jaune après à la au soleil après
mettre de l'eau pour vienir bleu c'est
ça fa les peinture un transfert sur cha
de
[Musique]
photo de
soleil et
soleil second et tu saurais refaire si
on te donne sur te donne tout ce qu'il
faut ah oui
ben un
stage embaucher oui pas souci Johann est
plasticien il propose une technique
multimédia de la mise en scène à la
photo puis à la projection pour passer
sur la peinture c'est tout un processus
qui permet de toucher à plusieurs
techniques et de déplacer son regard sur
les choses en fait c'est un atelier qui
s'appelle corps espace image on s'est
basé
sur plusieurs projets d'artistes connu
ou moins connu qui mettent en jeu le
corps pour fabriquer des images des
artistes assez
bondus des one minut
sculpture en fait l'idée c'est dans
corps espace image c'est de remettre le
corps en jeu dans la fabrication des
images
intégrer tout un travail de mise en
scène avec des objets qu'on trouve dans
un contexte proche pour ensuite décider
à un moment donné de figer cette chose
là de la photographier et c'est cette
photo là qu'on va projeter sur du des
grandes feuilles de papier pour
réintroduire ensuite le geste dans le
dessin et après de pouvoir confronter
l'image photographique la mise en scène
et l'image dessinée comme ça on a une
espèce de petite fabrique de l'image où
le corps est toujours de toute façon
remis en question et remis en jeu déjà
avec les objets on essaie de modifier
les fonctions des objets c'est-à-dire
que une chaise ça va pas être une chaise
on va pas s'asseir dus on va l'utiliser
et on va faire par exemple de la chaise
autre chose et c'est le ça va être
pareil pour le corps c'estàdire qu'on va
utiliser le corps pour le mettre dans
une autre situation qui serait par
exemple un coid une masse un d'autres
rapports au corps qui sont pas forcément
liés
à la personne l'identité le donc on
essaie de de de réellement mettre des
situations qui sont hutes pour avoir des
images autres et du coup quand on est
sur la mise en image la photographie ou
le dessin déjà la photographie le dessin
et ben je leur dis que voilà le moment
où on commence à dessiner on est sur des
rapports de ligne de surface de couleur
de masse colorée et du coup on n'est pas
du tout sur ben voilà est-ce que je me
représente est-ce que c'est bien ou
est-ce que c'est pas bien si le procédé
paraît complexe les résidents du FAO
n'ont pour autant eu aucun mal à
s'approprier la technique c'est vous qui
avez choisi le le le carton sur la tête
oui pourquoi vous avez choisi ça
parce que ça me
plaît pour s'occuper un peu les main
trouve quand même les mains seulement
les mains le
corp et tout le monde on est artiste et
ma même moi je su
artiste je suis dedans c'est parti
don
il faut V dire ça il faut me pousser un
petit peu
après en
[Musique]
confiance cette approche d'expression
s'inscrit dans la continuuité du projet
d'établissement si l'objectif premier
est l'expression et l'épanouissement la
voix des arts permet de développer la
personne dans son ensemble alors c'est
un projet d'art plastique particulier
qui repose sur sur les pratiques
artistiques et sur la création
artistique comme source d'épanouissement
d'abord le plaisir mais aussi comme
théâtre d'acquisition de nouvelles
compétences qui seront réutilisables à
d'autres moments dans le quotidien de
chacun et le principe c'est aussi de se
dire
que la réalisation artistique peut être
une source
de
valorisation et d'expressions y compris
dans un monde qui n'ouvre pas forcément
toutes ces portes chacun continue
consciencieusement son œuvre après ces
TR jours de travail les travaux
s'accumulent prennent forme ils feront
l'objet d'une exposition prévue pour
l'anniversaire des 10 ans de
l'établissement l'exposition sera
ouverte à tous rendez-vous au mois de
juin pour une découverte de
l'intégralité des
[Musique]
travaux